and while the situation in Afghanistan a
rapidly deteriorates here in Germany
questions are being asked about Berlin's
responsibility to protect the people
left behind when its troops pulled out
calls are growing for Germany to rapidly
evacuate local support staff who helped
the armed forces in their mission the
Taliban view them as traitors and many
people who worked for foreign forces
have already been killed in the
onslaught well now Germany's foreign
minister heiko Moss announced plans to
relax visa requirements for support
staff to bring them to safety quickly
we have chartered planes to repatriate
German Embassy employees these flights
will also be available to our local
support staff who are still in
Afghanistan
the embassy in Kabul will remain
operational but we have decided that the
local aides who have not yet received a
Visa will be able to request them in
Germany that will considerably expedite
their departure from Afghanistan
Germany's foreign minister speaking
moments ago and NATO has just concluded
an urgent meeting discussing the
worsening situation in Afghanistan
Secretary General Jen stoltenberg LED
discussions with envoys from the 30
members of the transatlantic Alliance
well we think that it focused on the
evacuation of foreign Nationals from the
country a number of nations including
the US have already begun pulling out
their citizens let's get you the very
latest now DW correspondents Barrett
regert is in Brussels Branch okay we
understand the meeting has ended what
can you tell us
well after this extraordinary meeting
Ian stoltenberg the Secretary General of
NATO issues short statement saying that
NATO is very concerned about the
development in Afghanistan and that NATO
also wants to maintain its support for
the government and they also addressed
the Taliban saying that they will not be
recognized as a legal government if they
take over the rest of the country
all you know all the ambassadors were a
little bit surprised about the pace that
the Taliban are taking and there was
also criticism the United Kingdom said
it was a mistake to withdraw so quickly
without troops on the ground now there's
a real problem in Kabul in Afghanistan
and now we understand also that in in
the last couple of hours foreign
embassies in Kabul are suspending
operations is NATO keeping a diplomatic
presence in Kabul
yeah Denmark and Norway declared that
they will shut down the embassies
Germany and others will
cut operations down to a minimal
presence NATO is also keeping a very
slow a low number of diplomats and staff
there but they wouldn't tell how many
because of security reasons they don't
want to tell the Taliban what they're
actually doing but everybody is now
preparing for the worst case scenario
and that is
evacuating all personnel
uh remind us Barrett is NATO providing
support to the Afghan Security Forces at
the moment
yeah that's what they are claiming there
are some advisors left but there are no
combat troops anymore no boots on the
ground and the U.S is sending a 3 000
additional soldiers to Kabul but not to
support the fights but just to maintain
the withdrawal of diplomats and other
Personnel from Afghanistan back to the
United States and also Britain is
sending 600 troops but also not to fight
so the the support actually is
diminishing and the question is also
what happens to the United Nations
agencies and other and ngos and other
Personnel that is there that also has to
be withdrawn and to be secured and to be
pulled out in the future
DW's bar into eager to reporting from
Brussels thank you
I'd like to welcome now Paul Miller who
served in Afghanistan and was the
country director on the National
Security Council under both U.S
presidents George W bush and Barack
Obama sir a thank you so much for your
time welcome to DW news as someone who
served in Afghanistan how does it feel
to watch the Taliban run riot
well it's a heartbreaking to see what's
happening in Afghanistan right now for
me and I think for anybody who has spent
time working on the intervention there
trying to make life better for the
Afghans and trying to keep the United
States and our allies safe from
International terrorism it's a deeply
concerning situation and it certainly
does not feel good to watch this happen
is it getting harder to see a path of
victory for government forces or is
there still a way to push back the
Taliban
I'm afraid the way to push back the
Taliban would be to reintroduce
International military forces to give
the Afghan forces the support they need
whether that's air support Medevac
Logistics intelligence command and
control the kinds of things we have been
giving to the Afghans
for the last 10 years or more is the uh
what would be needed to push back the
Taliban right now I'm not sure there's
political will for that in Washington DC
or other capitals but that's what it
would that's what it would take to stop
the taliban's advance well as we're
having this conversation NATO is holding
crisis talks in Brussels looking at the
events of this past week what are their
options could we potentially see a
course correction
um it's hard to answer that question
there's a military component to it and a
political component militarily can we I
think that the United States and our
allies we have the resources uh there
are troops uh still a few on the ground
in Afghanistan and there's troops in the
region and forward deployed so could it
happen materially I think the answer is
yes the real question is politically is
there any appetite to re-intervene in
Afghanistan I I hear you say that NATO
is meeting right now my understanding is
that within the Biden Administration
there's really no appetite to relitigate
this decision President Biden has
emphasized several times in recent weeks
that he's comfortable with this decision
he feels no regrets about it and he said
he feels no responsibility for what's
happening in Afghanistan right now that
is so striking Mr Miller because I am so
happy that you brought that up because
President Joe Biden is currently facing
some very tough criticism for his
decision to follow through with the pull
out from some very high level generals
who spoken out to publicly but it is
falling on deaf ears are you surprised
by that
I am surprised I thought that President
Biden had a window of opportunity in
this first half year of his term to
repudiate the peace deal that President
Trump had signed because everybody knew
the peace deal was flawed and that the
Taliban were not abiding by it President
Biden had every opportunity to
reevaluate the situation and come up
with his own policy and maybe start
negotiations afresh from a different
posture a posturous strength against the
Taliban so I'm very surprised at the
decision he's made and the fact that
he's sticking with it day after day as
we see the situation deteriorate
in a frankly surreal development the U.S
is reportedly pleading with the Taliban
not to attack its Embassy should Kabul
fall or should they overtake Kabul what
message does that send to the Afghans
the message it sends to the Afghans is
that the United States that some of the
spokesmen for the American government uh
are indulging in some wishful thinking
uh and they are they're gearing their
public messaging towards the Taliban
audience not to the Afghan audience the
American audience or the international
audience
some of the American spokesmen Still
Believe there could be a negotiated
solution that the Taliban would actually
adhere to I think that's a fantasy I
think we all know that's not realistic
and yet it seems that some in the U.S
state Department still believe that it's
worth not Burning Bridges with the
Taliban I think the bird the Taliban
burned that bridge a long time ago
it's fear
my biggest fear is unfolding right now
my biggest fear is the Taliban
militarily taking over the country and
we return the clock to 1996. it will be
awful for the Afghans it will also
introduce a much higher risk of
international terrorism for the
International Community for the United
States and our allies Al Qaeda and its
copycats will find Safe Haven again in
Afghanistan and Pakistan
we had successfully kept them more
concerned with their survival over the
past 20 years than with planning new
attacks and there have been no major
International terrorist attacks
emanating from that region for 20 years
my biggest fear is we've undone that
progress they will find Safe Haven and
they will now be able to use that safe
haven to plan recruit train and
fundraise and we're watching this happen
in real time
Paul D Miller Afghanistan director at
the National Security Council under
presidents George W bush and Barack
Obama thank you sir for your time
thank you I'd like to take you now to
Kabul uh I'd like to welcome Mariam
atahi she's an activist for Women's and
Children's right thank you so much for
your time Maryam how are things in Kabul
right now
thank you so much right now where I am
the situation is dire and the taller one
is very close to kobold they took the
control of local Province which is very
close to Cornwall and the situation is
there people are stressing out
especially womans and there you could
see and you could see that on that you
could watch under your reports how
people are suffering especially the this
element people who displace from the
north provinces and also from the south
provinces people are in a very
human and very bad humanitarian
situations and people is stressing out
that maybe over a night or something
tomorrow or the day after tomorrow it's
all about I'm going to take the Cobble
and we are going to back to the 1996 and
with the same fate with the same
situation that everyone woman especially
who have gone through so much so much
during the Taliban regime and they are
scaring and I mean it's uh everybody is
scared what will happen and in the
situation it's very worse right now and
everybody is scaring I mean nobody can
focus and I mean we don't know what will
happen tomorrow Mariam what are your
fellow women activists and and friends
telling you in the areas that have been
overtaken by the Taliban what have their
experience has been right now
yeah I'm also a co-founder of woman a
feminine perspective campaign where we
are gathering and also collecting
stories from the rural area and a woman
who are living in the rural area so we
have been collecting the stories from
one who are living in the under a
Taliban control they are actually
um saying and they are sending their
narratives that the situation is not
good there is a lot of War women are not
allowed to go to school and they are
also kind of like
a kind of restrictions that they have
placed in the area and they are actually
telling this story that I mean that's
why most of the very young girls and
womans who have been displaced and came
to Kabul and living in a park is Parks
and living in the on the streets they're
telling us the the situation is very
worse and they can't go to school
they're not going out and they have been
asked to being asked to wear a hijab and
go cut
my in conclusion what is your biggest
fear I mean Kabul is now an island
basically on its own
um what do you fear most
well of course it's a big fear for all
of African women who especially work to
uh and live their life to change one
woman's situations and also
made a lot of efforts to bring a change
on woman's lives and also to have access
to their fundamental rights at least
going to school at least going to the
work and get out of their home Bears big
fears for me and for my field for other
women who are living in kobold and also
in the provinces that already tooken by
the Taliban is that if they come and ask
me to sit at home and not going to
get out and also at the same time I'm
also feared that if they come and also
killed me because for the past 20 years
as the kid for women's stress which was
against their ideology against what for
their politics I also have the fear and
also my other girls or the other woman
that I have known them they have fear
that they are scared that they have the
tolerant camps and they check home by
home and asking to ask to to give and to
be accountable for what we have done
during the past 14 years which was
against their ideology and and thoughts
these are the fears that we are really
really afraid we are really stressing
out that the Taliban is coming tomorrow
what will happen to to African woman
activist for Women's and Children's
rights in Afghanistan we wish you all
the very best
thank you